hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday September 4 2017 how's it going
how are you
happy [ __ ] Labor Day happy Labor Day
happy Labor Day you don't have to go to
[ __ ] work unless you're the guy that
owns the [ __ ] business then you never
get to sleep do you you should have
stopped with your first wife but you
threw her out and now you got a [ __ ]
twenty-something [ __ ] come and she
wants to spend all your money alright
sorry anyways oh you know something you
worked hard all year god damn it it's
nice that you got a [ __ ] a Monday off
isn't it don't you wish it was the way
it is in Europe I don't know how they do
it over there you know they all got
[ __ ] health insurance they get like
53 weeks off a year then that like the
whole [ __ ] continent shuts down in
August everybody just says [ __ ] it we're
not working and somehow it keeps going
there's because their countries is so
small though look at the little country
is that what it is over here it's so
[ __ ] big you know just a mole your
yard takes half the goddamn summer over
here all of us fat [ __ ] waddling around
a giant pieces of property riding a
four-wheeler shooting the guns you
[ __ ] live over there in Europe man
you get you got nothing you got a flat
you know you and five other guys [ __ ]
addicted to heroin want some baby drums
in a toilet
whatever that [ __ ] movie was you know
you had nothing oh maybe maybe you got a
house and it's got like that [ __ ]
it's got that roof that looks like a
bale of hay that someone braided in
looks like a weave but with like hey I
don't know what it is over there but all
I know is they still have castles some
of them still have kings and queens and
they they get they get like August off
it's just off you know when they get
free health care they pay a bunch of
[ __ ] taxes but I got to be honest you
pay a bunch of taxes here too
I think it's just because what
bigger got the wide-open [ __ ] roads
I'm gonna go with that I'm gonna go with
that and I'm never gonna read up about
it and that's what I'm gonna say if that
topics ever brought up like hey come on
come they get all this vacation time and
if a woman has a kid over there
she doesn't have to be back to work on
Monday how come that is I'll cuz their
little tiny countries you know they have
little tiny hospitals you know a little
tiny teeth that they don't brush you
know it's it's tits Europe what do you
do that's why their cars go better in
the corners they have little tiny
streets and they gotta thing kind of
zigzag around some [ __ ] you know that
that's basically what it is it's not
like America some woman gives birth on
Friday and then they ain't Jean make
sure you're [ __ ] here on Monday pump
that kid out do whatever it is you got a
dope
have you gotten to stick a weed whacker
of our or a [ __ ] reverse blower up
there and suck the kid out and be back
to work will give you Monday off then
you got to be here on Tuesday that's how
it works here in America everybody
wonders why we're so fat it has nothing
to do with our poison food
we're just stressed you know if you guys
didn't have a whole month to August off
over there in Europe I'd love to see if
you guys actually had the room [ __ ]
work over there and worry about you know
I need a new pancreas how am I going to
afford that right which is easily the
cost of at least three flat-screen TVs
that's the going rate for a pancreas if
I remember correctly all right if you
were dealing with that stress I'd like
to see how many [ __ ] doughnuts you be
eating you know speaking of which Billy
no fun Billy no fun is on his 18th day
of not boozing 18 days not boozing I
barely even met water tastes like at
this point you know I'm dropping weight
this is the time a night when it sucks
you know in the morning it's great I
wake up my stomach's flatter than it was
the day before I feel good but it's like
at night I mean Sunday night I don't
have to go to work on Monday I have
tomorrow off like all you guys well you
listening to it today you know
you can't tell me you know I mean as a
[ __ ] human being I I have to go out
and get [ __ ] hammered right I mean
what kind of mean I if I don't die I
mean if I was running the CIA I'd be
there's this guy in Isis see some sort
of religious fanatic Oh Billy red cakes
Oh Billy red velvet I'm staying away
from the sugar I'm being an angel I'm
being an angel cuz I might have some
acting work in in October so I gotta
make sure I'm down in my fighting weight
am i fighting weight a buck 72 that's
what I need to be at whenever I shoot
something you know all these [ __ ]
actresses out here talk about how it's
so hard for them as if a guy can go on
and be a bloated fat [ __ ] and not get
[ __ ] for it okay if that's not how it
works they can get to you through social
media they go right at you and they tell
you that you're a bloated fat [ __ ] what
happened to you
you got old whija-- hair go all of that
[ __ ] you know what I mean but you know
you know what it is about people they
look out their own [ __ ] heads all
right they look at the world in a
two-dimensional way they look out their
heads they observe something and then
they put it their head and they process
it with their previous experience and
then to them that is the truth that is
what's going on in the world they look
at it from their [ __ ] angle they
don't realize it that it's 360 degrees
which is why South Park is the greatest
[ __ ] show of all time as far as I'm
concerned because no matter what problem
they attack they hit it from all sides
the red side the blue side from the
north to south east the West you know
I'm saying you like that that was the
longest [ __ ] compliment ever
Oh Josh Adam Maya's from the goddamn
comedy Jim
Josh Adam Meyers bill burr I'm taping my
Monday morning podcast you're one of our
first callers how are you
I'm just curious I wasn't aware that
that happened was that a big news story
in the world of sports you know as as a
[ __ ] lover of the Celtics as a
Celtics lover I hated the [ __ ] trade
because I loved Isiah he was like a mini
Big Papi who's on his way who's gonna
have a street named after him but that
it's it's a business now and this all
goes back I think to the Miami Heat all
those pylon teams back to the Kobe Shaq
Lakers when whenever it stopped being
bird bird Celtics magic Lakers Isiah
[ __ ] the Pistons Jordan with the
Bulls and everybody just jumped around
now it's over I thought you're gonna ask
about the cigar no I don't give a [ __ ]
just ring the doorbell and I'll stop and
I'll finish it later
all right don't hate don't ring the
doorbell my daughter's sleeping just
text me right see
anyways the most roundabout compliment
ever for South Park I had no idea I was
gonna say that so I am as of this
morning I've 179 pounds in six ounces
once every nine point six so I'm trying
to lose three a week so next week on
Friday I need to be I need to be 177 all
right I just said hit pause I'm in the
[ __ ] doghouse I just woke up my
daughter oh my God my wife is [ __ ]
pissed at me yeah boy yeah boy oh
brother
alright this is the Monday morning
podcast and I'm gonna be [ __ ]
whispering for the rest of this goddamn
thing
the hell was I talking about yes so next
week I want to be 177 pounds by Friday
and then 170 for the next week and then
I'll be 171 and then if I get this
acting gig I'll be where I need to be so
I was gonna take a month off from
boozing but if I get this acting gig
then I'm just not gonna booze like right
on through to the end of the [ __ ]
shoot and then when that's over okay
I'm gonna get like one of those
kegerators and I'm gonna fill it up with
[ __ ] whiskey and I'm gonna be
underneath it and it's gonna be glorious
I don't know I don't know what my
[ __ ] problem is I should go to a
meeting and just see what that's like I
went to a meeting a long time ago and I
got arrested for drinking and driving
and one of the requirements was you had
to go to a AAA meeting two of them or
something like that
all I remember I was just like these
guys are [ __ ] drunks I mean I drink I
don't I don't [ __ ] drink these guys
had like lunacy stories talking about
like [ __ ] bleeding out their ass and
going right to the liquor store the next
day you know what I mean like not eating
food for like just crazy crazy crazy
[ __ ] stories so I just was sitting
there going I am I'm just a drunk these
people got a [ __ ] problem I'm telling
you right now if you ever just want to
see you know some of the most [ __ ] up
people on the planet just go to an AAA
meeting these [ __ ] people man you
know if fingers are like stuck together
from like cigarette smoke you know what
I mean they got like just a mean I can't
be I'm just being an [ __ ] I have no
idea what a [ __ ] AAA meetings like I
know it's like you get like a little
trinket if you do it for a while you
know get six days you know just [ __ ]
you know you know addictive people
they're [ __ ] they they can never stop
talking about themselves right so think
it's got to go up there oh my come and
get so much [ __ ] for this I don't give a
[ __ ] I think it's about time somebody
[ __ ] put a a in its place right once
you grow up and white-knuckle it like
the rest of us you got to go join a
[ __ ] group everybody sits down and
[ __ ] makes an Afghan together you
know it's funny that I actually would
love to be part of a group when I'm at
golf and look this past week you know
and I went with a buddy mining he was
like a member of a Country Club on like
this is [ __ ] cool
it's really cool you know bunch of guys
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] having a great time
all that [ __ ] that everybody [ __ ]
gives you a rough time for you know they
always make fun of guys hanging out now
if they all hang out together like they
did there has to be like mocked for some
[ __ ] reason it's fun
you just sit around breaking each
other's balls that's all it was I went
there and it was everybody was [ __ ]
cool and everybody was just busting
chops the whole [ __ ] time and then
you go out in golf and everybody's just
giving each other [ __ ] and you laughing
and you smoking cigars and you're
gambling and [ __ ] it's it's fun for
whatever [ __ ] reason I don't know if
you do that now I don't know for some
reason that that's attacked you know I
don't I don't know what I don't know
what it is I don't know what the [ __ ] is
you supposed to be doing but I can tell
you I did enjoy it
and speaking of enjoying [ __ ] I know I'm
all over the map I found I got caught up
with the last you know today's Formula
One race and the previous one like a
week ago with two weeks ago I missed it
and I have to tell you I loved the Force
India team before I watched the previous
race and now I I will [ __ ] love that
team forever I will love that [ __ ]
team forever at the very least Esteban o
Khan and Sergio Perez everybody else was
[ __ ] was racing to not lose you know
didn't want to [ __ ] up these [ __ ]
guys went in there you know what I mean
you ever watch a hockey fight and in the
guys is so good at it they barely even
punch each other the best ones is we
just you grabbed my shoulder I grabbed
your shoulder we just [ __ ] beat the
[ __ ] out of each other you know that's
what these guys did they went old-time
hockey with like racing they're on the
same team they slammed into each other
twice
they don't even give a [ __ ] that it's a
teammate this was like some sort of
bloodsport that they were doing
everybody else is out there like oh my
god that's my teammate I need to I'm
really literally making fun of the other
teams for actually doing this smart
thing I love that they did it
I love last year when Hamilton and
[ __ ] Nicki Minaj whatever his [ __ ]
name was I can't remember this [ __ ]
name what the hell is guys named Nicki I
want it now I'm taking my toys and going
home I'm getting married now
Rosberg right Nico Rosberg that's what
it was when they slammed into each other
they did that a couple of times I like
that and I love how these [ __ ]
drivers there's all of this [ __ ] where
they don't like each other this you know
like Sebastian Vettel doesn't like Lewis
Hamilton Kimi räikkönen doesn't like
Valtteri Bottas it's it literally is
[ __ ] Days of Thunder it's tremendous
and this past week's race was great
yesterday as far as watching a Lance
stroll getting 18 years old he's lined
up on the front row next to Lewis
Hamilton who's just the [ __ ] greatest
driver he just is he is I know Mercedes
has the best [ __ ] cars right now but
you don't give me a [ __ ] break it's
not like Ferraris any sort of a slouch
right I don't know you could argue that
Daniel Ricardo's just as good he's just
not riding driving a car is good maybe
that's what the [ __ ] it is I don't know
what it is but I really enjoyed
yesterday's race and the previous one
how do you not love Force India out
there with the pink cars the fuchsia
cars slamming into each other it looked
like me and my brother at a [ __ ]
carnival don't you'd be like those two
guys are related like you wouldn't know
we would if we got into bumper cars we
would know I didn't give a [ __ ] about
anybody else out there other than
slamming into my own [ __ ] family
member what was the point it hitting
somebody else I couldn't laugh at him in
the car ride home I'd never see him
again
so anyways I guess they go to Singapore
next one of these years I'm gonna line
up a stand-up date with that race over
there
I want to try to go to a couple of year
because I'm a [ __ ] lunatic
so I went to Montreal this year and I'm
also going to the race in Austin Texas
provided there's not another you know
[ __ ] hurricane like that one that hit
Houston Jesus Christ anyways
I actually you know I want to tweet out
something you guys there was actually
something where you could send like
[ __ ] diapers and that type of stuff
for my kids can't imagine it but that
has babies and everything you got to
take care of that seemed like a really
cool thing to do the very least at least
you can [ __ ] do
so anyways I'm behind with my MotoGP
racing I got to get caught up on that
but I have to be I've been oh so this
this race and Italy was one of my
favorite races just because of what was
going on in like position four five and
six
[ __ ] lunatic racing and I just wish
they could somehow do something to the
cars that that happened in the first and
second position because once again
Lewis Hamilton you know he gets to the
first corner first he comes out in first
place and then that's it he's in the
front of the race for the rest of the
[ __ ] race and then that's just it
it's over he's driving in clean air his
cars too [ __ ] fast now you got a hope
that the car breaks down or he [ __ ] up
which isn't going to happen and but I
did enjoy all that other stuff but
congratulations to Lewis Hamilton for
winning another one he now is ahead of
Sebastian Vettel and I believe the
Mercedes team as a team is ahead of
everybody else too so they're [ __ ]
crushing it and I think it's gonna be
all downhill from here so I'm hoping the
[ __ ] Ferrari team son because they're
the closest ones can step it up and I
like both those guys I like Kimmy Kimmy
raking it he always seems [ __ ] pissed
off getting penalties and [ __ ] I relate
to the angry guys that's why I like
force India they're gonna [ __ ] slam
into each other it's tremendous it's
tremendous you know it's childish it's
stupid I love when that guy with that
former race car [ __ ] champion I don't
know what his name is the commentary
just goes oh dear boys boys what are you
doing Dave
it's all like [ __ ] parental with him I
[Music]
wanted to see I watched the qualifying -
I love when it rains out dude oh I
forgot the greatest quote I've heard
since I started watching formula racing
after the [ __ ] Force India cars hit
for the second time I think it was that
Okan guy he says over his radio he goes
to his [ __ ] crew chief or whatever he
goes what the [ __ ] seriously what the
[ __ ] like flipping meanwhile he's gone
like a hundred eighty miles an hour
he sounds like me when I Drive to work
and he's doing like you know 180 200
miles an hour and he's gonna [ __ ]
flip each other off and they never flip
II just you know the Europeans [ __ ] they
they give the AE with the [ __ ] hand
somebody's gotta flip somebody off you
know I mean or if they're right on their
ass slam on the brakes like you do on
the highway stop [ __ ] tailgate I
wasn't tailgate I was drafting all right
enough of this [ __ ] I know a lot of you
guys don't even watch this [ __ ] but um
all right
let's plow ahead here I I was uh did a
casino I already forget the name of it I
was in a casino right outside of San
Diego and I did it two years ago and I
flew down in our 44 and today or
yesterday I flew in a I don't know what
the [ __ ] it was to be honest with you
let me see if I can look up the name of
this helicopter this helices turbine
engine which is a jet engine and it was
[ __ ] humble the whole thing was
hydraulic I [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] what
helicopter was so basically I trained on
the r22 our 22 is like driving a car
that has drum brake drum brakes no power
steering you don't I mean and you have
to like [ __ ] control the wipers
yourself you know like in the 1920s like
Laurel and Hardy you gotta like move it
side to side which is also why I love
that thing because you're really flying
if you'll hold in a hover you're [ __ ]
doing it then you move up to the r44 and
this is kind of weird
where it's like the the collective and
the cyclic are both hydraulic okay
that's the your power and then how you
steer the [ __ ] you hold with your hands
basically and then if but for whatever
reason your foot pedals are not
hydraulic they just manual your own
precious so you're dealing with like
really finessing it barely having to
touch it up top and then your drum
breaks down the bottom it's just it's a
very odd feeling and I fly out of
Burbank and there's always a [ __ ]
tailwind when you're going in to set it
down
it's so [ __ ] annoying like right
behind you full blast I don't know where
it comes from every time in fact I saw
this student that was learning over
there what he would do was he went he
would go to set it down he would just he
would just face the wind and set it down
and then go inside and get the wheels
and then put him on the thing and then
just turn the helicopter around and as
much as it was funny I was like that's a
great [ __ ] idea I would rather do
that you know cuz you landed next to
other helicopters I don't wanna [ __ ]
anybody else's [ __ ] up so anyways this
thing was like a was like a six seater
and I got a picture you know Dean Dale
rain go look him up on Twitter he's he
tweeted out a picture I'll [ __ ] I'll
retweet it and it's like the words I'm
staying in front of the coolest
helicopter I ever flew and I'm talking
when someone whoever took the picture so
I look like a [ __ ] I may look like an
[ __ ] anyway who's kidding no but it
was I would say the most amazing machine
I've ever gotten the chance to operate
and it was like it was like a sports car
in the air with like that like the
tightest most responsive [ __ ]
suspension you could possibly think of
without the rough ride because you're
not on the ground you just going through
the air didn't feel any turbulence
whatsoever and I just know when you take
off in the r22 and you push the stick
forward right I mean I don't know how
long it is it's a good eight nine
seconds until you want to get up to 53
knots that's the optimal you
speed to get out to get the most rate of
climb and it takes you good I feels like
forever
eight nine seconds this [ __ ] thing it
was like maybe two and a half seconds
and it was up to speed you just pulled
the stick back and you [ __ ] shot up
in the air I've never been it was really
intimidating but once I just sort of I
watched my instructor I have to times
through the start and start up and shut
down of it it's like it's it's not that
bad it's just intimidating at first and
then you get wants you know where to
look which is basically your manifold
pressure your altitude and how fast
you're going then I'll see you trim once
you know where those are all the other
[ __ ] it's just like well you know a
[ __ ] horns gonna go off if there's a
problem anywhere else right anyways it
was fun as [ __ ] and went down and we did
the gig and I think I'm gonna start
doing that like I'm doing a podcast
festival for the all things comedy
Network in the end of October and if I
don't get this acting gig and I'm in LA
I'm gonna fly out in a helicopter
I got a Vegas gig I'm gonna do that one
in the helicopter too and that way I can
get my keep my hours up stay current and
while going out making money so I'm
renting the helicopter but I'm earning
money right and in a way I get to fly
private without having to blow all this
money on a [ __ ] stupid-ass jet which
is stupid right those [ __ ] private
jets as [ __ ] stupid as health you get
in them you can't even stand up it's the
dumbest thing ever you're way better you
can spend 190th the money on a
first-class [ __ ] ticket and you are
in awe you're on like a [ __ ] cruise
ship you can stand you can stand up when
you take a piss you don't have to bend
over at the [ __ ] neck you know I know
they make bigger jets but those things
are like you know you're gonna fly from
Boston to Rhode Island it's gonna cost
you like a [ __ ] $300,000 I don't know
how people I don't know anybody flies
private to be honest with you I have no
[ __ ] idea just go to a mom-and-pop
Airport get on JetBlue or virgin that's
the way to do it use some miles bump
yourself up to a big
see you're gonna get a pilot who's
psyched he's making a ton of [ __ ]
money you get on those little ones those
for that poo you might not make it [ __ ]
right I know that's been that's been my
experience they're trying to they're
trying to get a gig flying one of the
bigger ones so they can actually make
money instead of flying some little
[ __ ] six seater you know it is I'm
out of my [ __ ] element I don't know
what I think about that [ __ ] I just have
heard about how much it [ __ ] cost all
right let me let me read the let me read
the [ __ ] advertising here for this
week all right what do we got here Oh
draftkings everybody kay do you like to
gamble on sports you want to make some
[ __ ] money these are the guys it's
not too late to get closer to the game
you love with draft kings one-week
fantasy football this Sunday draft kings
is hosting a $100,000 pick um contest
that is totally free to enter all right
pick'em is the newest way to play
one-week fantasy football drafting your
team is faster than ever
draftkings has organized players into
eight tiers all you have to do is select
one player from each tier choose between
public contests choose between public
contests with big cash prizes or private
contests where private contests are
where you can compete against a group of
your friends draftkings also has a
beginner and casual contests where you
can play against people of a similar
skill level the best part is you get to
draft a new team each week without any
commitment so get to draftkings.com now
and use promo code bird to play in
draftkings free contests with $100,000
dollars in total prizes this Sunday use
my promo code Burpee you are to play for
free this Sunday that's promo code burr
at draft kings.com eligibility
restrictions apply
see draft kings.com for detail speaking
of which the New England Patriots the
five times Superbowl defending champions
the the off the often criticized for
absolutely no [ __ ] reason you know
all the time had another guy bring up
[ __ ] deflategate I always tell him
it's like they did not get convicted of
deflating balls you [ __ ] [ __ ] that
was laughed out of court for the 90
million time and then the suspension was
was was cancelled remember that he was
supposed to be suspended and they took
it to court and it was laughed out of
court and the judge said you're wasted
why did you waste my [ __ ] time with
this that's what happened and then you
know the United States of America you
cannot get tried twice for the same
offense that's a habeas hearsay
something or other right you can't be
can't be [ __ ] double jeopardy you
can't [ __ ] do that so the NFL found a
loophole they just went back to court
and said is the NFL a corporation and
the judge was like yes and then they
said does a corporation have the right
to suspend its employee and the judge
said yes and they said fine we're
corporation Tom Brady is our employee
and he is suspended and that's what they
did that's why he got suspended
not because they proved anything you
[ __ ] dopes and by the way the guy who
caught the the alleged by the way under
inflated [ __ ] ball by the way the
Colts also allegedly had 200 fellated
balls but who gives a [ __ ] then I went
in all the championships right the guy
who caught the ball tested positive for
steroids this past season nobody gives a
[ __ ] all right
lootcrate everybody lootcrate be the
envy of your friends and get 100%
exclusive crates at loot crate calm /
xxx and enter my code xxx well I guess I
got the wrong [ __ ] copy didn't I I
don't know what to do with this X second
what is this I never know what this
[ __ ] cowboy I'm just gonna read it
and get X X X amount of dollars off any
new subscription september's loot crate
theme is robotic on a quest for epic
gear housewares and collectibles loot
crate has it loot crate offers an epic
range of pop-culture items for less than
$20 a month if you're more of a
fanatical fashionista than try loot
where
monthly wearable and accessories with
cult classics in your favorite
franchises if you want to get fancy get
a bigger box and an even bigger loop
with loot crate DX want to geek out your
pet try loot pets offer expires
September 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific whether
they be poor speak many of your favorite
characters are robotic and September's
loot crate you'll find items from Star
Wars Star Trek aliens in Blade Runner
let me see I mean those robots I can
name c-3po r2d2 r5 d4 that's a that's a
good one that's like naming an offensive
lineman then there was that one on
[ __ ] Buck Rogers some of that stupid
thing Beedie Beedie Beedie remember that
before talk to go Beedie Beedie Beedie
Beedie and then would say something I'd
never understood it somebody sat in the
writers room and pitched then what if
the robot said Beedie Beedie Beedie and
then said what he was gonna say it
somehow there wasn't like a deafening
amount of silence and be like what the
[ __ ] did you just say get out of this
room alright one lucky subscriber will
also win a mega crate of seriously epic
proportions you have until the 19th
September 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific to
subscribe and receive that month's crate
and when the cutoff happens that it's
that's it it's over go to loot crate
calm slash burn enter my code bur be URR
to save $3 off on any new subscription
today I wish I had more information on
that but I don't all right here we go
what are we going ah buh doo doo doo me
undies me undies who remembers our 5 d 4
boo doo doo doo b undies me undies they
even make them for the horse nice and
soft up against your [ __ ]
you know you [ __ ] love it don't say
it's not nice and comfy up against your
snatch and they make him even for your
ball bag they'll take out the wrinkles
alright me undies you want to look good
in your underwear and be comfortable
right right but that
perfect balance is hard to find don't
sacrifice style or comfort
check out my undies comm and find the
best pair of underwear in the world talk
about why me on these is the best
underwear you will ever own
feel free to improvise Jesus cry don't
[ __ ] know because it feels good up
against your undercarriage you know what
I mean
you know when you go to buy a car and
then they go here you want to you want
to get the [ __ ] undercoating this is
the undercoating you know you buy two
pair of pants right what are you gonna
have you can have your [ __ ] Levi's
chafing up against you junkie can't have
that would it be great if there was some
[ __ ] soft velvety Greg Louganis
speedo type of underwear out there well
thank God there is with me undies for
the fellas me undies diamond scene pouch
like a rhinestone bow bag cradles your
jewels and gives you stuff to support it
needs without feeling too tight you know
I love about that song Rhinestone Cowboy
I love when he goes uh what is it all oh
yeah and he goes and offers coming over
the phone offers coming over the phone
you only have to you have to be in
[ __ ] show business or be
self-employed to know how great that
line is offers coming over the phone
after years of having your hat in your
hand
begging the [ __ ] do anything to
finally get to that level where people
actually want you and you get to stand
there and be like you like me really
like all right so you got diamond
encrusted balls right ladies will love
this soft eco-friendly fabric I did my
screen go so soft and touchable gross
100% satisfaction guarantee I don't know
why they talk about their [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they have so soft and
touchable makes me feel like a creep a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
the guarantee you will love we guarantee
a guarantee that you'll love your your
undies or your money back right now my
undies have an exclusive offer for just
my listeners and anybody else they
advertise with the [ __ ] [ __ ] get
20% off your first pair and free
shipping and the undies is so sure you
will love your their underwear they even
offer 100% satisfaction guarantee your
you order a pair and if you don't love
your first pair get a full refund this
is a no-brainer to try 20% off free
shipping and I'm since a stock guarantee
what [ __ ] are you waiting for
[ __ ] you waiting for buddy you want
to have soft nuts under your [ __ ]
overalls you got your buck shop in that
little front pocket so with that front
pockets foreign overalls that little
thing there is that where they put their
buckshot
it's great it's nice and snug doesn't
fall out when I'm on a four wheeler this
is limited this is a limited time offer
so what the [ __ ] are you waiting for
start wearing the best goddamn underwear
of your life it changed my life
evidently according to the copy it's
time to let me undies change yours go to
me undies calm slash bar right [ __ ]
now
alright Dollar Shave Club dude oh my god
they never proved that the balls were
under-inflated every which they didn't
by the way everyone knows Dollar Shave
Club ships amazing raises for a few
bucks what you might not know is that
Dollar Shave Club also has products -
pretty much for pretty much everything
else you need in the bathroom body wash
shampoo hair gel lip balm everything at
the store there are too many options and
you can't tell the difference between
any of them it's overwhelming
you feel like Robin Williams and Moscow
on the Hudson right when he walks into
the grocery store and he [ __ ] faints
and he sticks his head up that girl's
dress you remember that at the store
that too many options you can't tell the
very said that alright then if you have
any questions that Clark usually doesn't
know the difference and usually can't
[ __ ] find him because they got a
skeleton crew at 9:00 in the morning now
they're not and plus they're not experts
on the products dollars shape clubs
makes it easy and convenient for you to
upgrade your shave and your bathroom now
you don't have to step foot in a store
to get high-quality shave and grooming
products Dollar Shave Club delivers them
right to your door if you're sick of the
nonsense at the store now's the time to
try Dollar Shave Club for a limited time
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving
away their [ __ ]
shower shave start except two new
members this is why I love Dollar Shave
Club they just put curses in there they
got a [ __ ] shower shave starter set for
new members for only five dollars this
starter set features their executive
razor this is just brilliant this is
just for else single guys [ __ ] shower
shave there you go
pack it all up and three trial size
versions of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh and clean so
fresh and so clean and your first box
you receive their [ __ ] shea butter
body wash and one wipe Charlies one way
shally butt wipes you will also receive
their executive razor which includes
their premium weighted hand weighty
handle and focus set of cartridges after
the first box replacement cartridges are
sent for only a few bucks a month this
offers exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com to l-shaped clubs
high quality products will have you
covered from face to cheek to butt
cheeks from face cheeks to butt cheek
sorry there's no better time to [ __ ]
try the club now my god there's still
one more sorry ProFlowers ProFlowers
with the fee get some me flowers for
Labor Day talk about the last time he
spontaneously surprised someone was
something completely unexpected and how
it felt I remember I stuck this gun and
this little kid's face one time and I
was like I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you and
his parents were freaking out and oh my
god did I laugh talk about what the rose
bouquet recently sent to you by profiles
look like you know your overall
impression of it well I didn't get one
and so I have no impression of it sounds
nice maybe Andrew got it do you have any
more requests and could I just read this
[ __ ] ProFlowers wants to help you
surprise someone for no reason at all
while also surprising you with this
special deal for my listeners no
ProFlowers wants to sell flowers during
months when you don't have to sell them
you know after you know what to [ __ ]
buy them that's why they want you we
want you to buy our just say listen we
got a ton of [ __ ] flowers left over
from Mother's Day can you buy these
things before they die we got a great
[ __ ] deal for you and if you
[ __ ] give him to your wife for no
goddamn reason at all she's probably
gonna blow you okay this is what should
be in the copy instead of this get 20%
off any of their unique summer rose
bouquets or any other bouquet for $29
they're colorful rainbow roses are
always a hit and if you aren't sure what
to send someone ProFlowers bouquets are
guaranteed to last at least 7 days guys
just [ __ ] do this for your wife it's
easy alright go to proflowers.com use my
code name per do you want to get a
[ __ ] I may be a little handy at the
[ __ ] and I hop under the table to make
the table a little more sticky gross
sorry this is what you need to do all
the dopes buy flowers on Mother's Day
they buy them on [ __ ] you know
birthdays and they buy them on on
[ __ ] Valentine's Day alright if you
want to up your [ __ ] if you want to
stay up in the pros and hit 300 okay you
got to spray it all over the field
alright so one of these times you just
just gets August or is it September yeah
Sept who gets to have [ __ ] wife or
girlfriend flowers in September nobody
be the person that [ __ ] does it and
get your dick sucked today alright there
you go alright booze line up Oh
beautiful I was hoping people gonna send
these in alright I I talked last week
and you know I got back into baseball
and uh that Yankees Red Sox things
heating up again we better meet in the
playoffs it has to happen it's been too
[ __ ] long I ended up [ __ ] Yankees
took three out of four so I broke even
all this [ __ ] talked and all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] talking and it just we
ended up just being even but I was
talking about you know just watching
baseball I did my booze lineup of like
whiskey scotches and Bourbons alright I
don't just do scotches okay this isn't
like the [ __ ] this is an MLB when
Babe Ruth played alright this is any
anybody can show up as long as you Brown
now if tequila is also welcome so this
would be my lineup I always change the
lineup I would say this week Johnnie
Walker Blue is leading off you got to
start with some strong [ __ ] right Pappy
Van Winkle is in second
and then I would put uh angels Envy at
third
McCallum rare castes rare cask is bat
and cleanup
alright then I'd have yep II Calle fifth
and you know once you get to the middle
order this is just when I just want to
get [ __ ] up right those other ones
angels envies also what a good one just
to get [ __ ] up on you know it's not
that expensive either then you get to
the middle of the order but it's like
I'm staying at home when I'm getting
drunk by myself or I'm getting drunk
with a friend of mine that appreciates
good whiskey bourbon or whatever when I
get in the middle then it's like
yippee-ki-yay patron silver maybe I put
grand patron where I put angels Envy
that's why I get that okay grand patron
and [ __ ] the third spot then I got
yippee-ki-yay then I got [ __ ] Angels
Envy and then Johnny Walker Black okay
those are the next three so then you got
eight and nine and that's when you know
you just have [ __ ] just people coming
over they just want to get shit-faced
then you just got to go makers mark a
[ __ ] Jack Daniels you know and then if
you just have a complete [ __ ]
[ __ ] do you just give a red label
[ __ ] Johnnie Walker alright so here's
this person's booze line up alright he
goes I love your idea about doing a
booze alcohol battling lineup here's my
submission leading off Kentucky tavern I
never heard of this this is what I love
it's gonna give me new [ __ ] to try
dependable a little rough around the
edges but you know this guy's gonna get
on pace at a 400 clip even if he has to
lean into one every now and then I love
that this person broke it all down then
give me your scouting reports to when
you send these in batting second
Hornitos what the [ __ ] is that
Hornitos can be streaky at times but
still has a little bit of a pop if you
mix it with grapefruit soda dude you're
in your second guy you're already mixing
it with something alright no [ __ ] hang
on a second speaking of that summit Josh
just asked me if I had this soda no I
don't I got to do a voice text here
get the Fanta orange with the Mexican
sugar there you go
all right that's right when I'm [ __ ]
not boozing I actually drink Fanta
orange soda it's kind of nice cuz it's
really sweet and then he got the smoke
you know it's not redundant remember big
night when that lady got the pasta and
then she also ordered mashed potatoes
and the guy wouldn't do it because it
was two starches you know why would you
have a cigar and then drink something
really PD it's like [ __ ] redundant
you want some a sweet kind of alcohol
I'm not actually I do okay so batting
third this guy has bullet this is your
franchise player he makes everyone
around him a little better plus he's
gonna give you a team friendly long-term
contract that won't have you paying
luxury taxes dude this guy's great you
know he took a funny idea now he's
taking it to an even funnier level all I
did was just get I got a breakdown each
player now all right batting cleanup
Knob Creek he goes can you tell him a
bourbon drinker I can never keep him
straight he goes bottom line is if
there's any Ducks left on the pond this
guy is there to deliver the knockout
punch I got to tell you the way he's
describing this lineup he's definitely
making the playoffs if not [ __ ]
winning the pennant batting fifth
smirnoff vodka okay definitely nothing
to write home about but when surrounded
with the right personnel there's always
potential for magic you know what my
vodka is my go-to vodka I like Belvedere
Oh Belvedere come here boy I like that
better than Grey Goose Grey Goose is
just like that's like soft rock like
easy listening you know what I mean I
like Belvedere it's got a little more of
a [ __ ] bite to it but I don't know
much about vodkas either batting six
Johnnie Walker Black now you might be
now might be a good time to mention I'm
in my early thirties hey cuz this guy is
a September call-up you're not quite
ready to add them to your 40 man roster
just yet but he's for a couple but he's
up for a cup of coffee because you know
he's going to be an important part of
your future yeah maybe can get on base
and steal second
batting seventh oh Jesus dude this is
unforgivable if you're in your thirties
this is unforgivable and I respect you
that you can still drink this
Jagermeister Wow Wow
you often find yourself wondering why
this guy is even still around and yet
you feel you can remember you wait and
yet you can you feel like you can
remember a time when he was actually
pretty good yeah he's like the [ __ ]
one of those guys we had just like you
know like Vince Carter still play that's
not fair to Vince Carter because Vince
Carter was one of the greatest [ __ ]
you know I I think the best dunker of
all [ __ ] time hi I'm certainly the
highest jumper I I apologize I shouldn't
have said Vince Carter I was the first
guy I thought of he's like yeah yeah
do you ever went like Giambi was playing
on the Colorado Rockies it's like one of
those deals all right Captain Morgan
batting eighth definitely a role player
this this side that's like you catch her
this guy could be a superstar but he's
got a bit of a sweet tooth and always
shows up to spring training 20 pounds
overweight
I always the Panda still you know he's
good for a sac fly in a key situation
yeah one of these guys just has to
you're out there for defense you know
he's not hitting for average all right
batting ninth wild turkey American honey
and he writes oh Jesus you asked him to
lay down a bunt and you just know he's
going to hit into an inning-ending
double play every damn time by the way
if it's if it's a close one
I'm putting in Buffalo Trace in place of
Jager as a defensive substitution
through this guy's brilliant so that's
my lineup thanks for the idea I enjoyed
putting this together even if you don't
read it now do it I love that you broke
it all down all right here's another
guys lineup all right his whiskey line
up bullet Eagle rare batting third
Macallan 12
batting fourth angels envy cask strength
I never had that D H I might [ __ ] up
some of the names of these valve
Balvenie 12 years single malt
Glen Leavitt French oak I can't deal
with the florals
I don't like the floors I like more the
PD thing like that Glenn Levitz I never
been able to quite handle those but I
respect them they're definitely in the
Hall of Fame of booze
now [ __ ] he's gonna stop by a talk of
not Jesus Christ what is he talking
about nah [ __ ] he's gonna stop by taco
truck to get the [ __ ] booze no no the
soda I mean hang on let me hit pause and
straighten this out all right I'm back
so anyways Glen Levitt French oak six
number seven Willy pot still reserved
never heard of that one
number eight Jefferson's ocean aged at
sea Jesus sounds like low tide [ __ ] to
me number nine Hudson Bay starting
pitcher is blends oh I forgot to do a
starting pitcher middle reliever giving
you a reliable couple innings makers 46
closer is Elijah Craig barrel proof do
it I love everybody going with the
starting pitches then you got to have
you middle really actually had middle
relief oh my god dude this is this is
endless and then you know see you're
gonna get some real big-time booze
hounds that nine you know positions in
the batting lineup are not going to be
enough they can have to go think about
that like I don't know do like a
football team 11 offensive players this
isn't fair to people over in Europe go
ahead give me your [ __ ] lineups and
use all the [ __ ] soccer terminology
maybe I'll learn something all right
here's another not last booze line up
here dear Billy no fun no fuss no muss
no brainer in answer to your request for
our batting lineups of booze I'm not
much of a drinker anymore so I'll go the
other way and do my recreational drug
lineup I love it I love it you guys have
taken this idea and running with it this
is tremendous all right number one weed
number two black hash preferably from
Nepal
number three magic mushrooms batting
cleanup LSD preferably purple owlsley
never tried it but according to Ken
Casey it was the best number five
ecstasy pure and uncut number six can of
mine I don't want this number seven
cocaine pure and uncut cocaine pure and
uncut should be [ __ ] that sounds like
a speedster man get him on base he
[ __ ] steal second then you have LSD
[ __ ] bring him home with a single to
right I don't know
running on a full count you're not gonna
catch that guy he might score from first
alright number eight peyote peyote
number nine mescaline pure and uncut hey
Bill on Thursday you were talking about
the sound of drums in the 70s I watched
this recently and thought it would be
informative to you over overhead mic
with a compressor on it you guys have to
watch this if you're into any type of
music I actually watched this thing and
it's do you know that sound of Phil
Collins drums the famous drum fill from
in the air tonight
that gogogogogogo don't don't though it
was you gotta watch this video how they
came up with that drum sound was an
accident
and then everybody used it and it
literally became the sound of the 80s
and now it's back I guess Taylor Swift
used it in some song called 1989 and all
that but if you just if you're into that
nerdy audio stuff like I found this
outbreak my [ __ ] drum teacher Davie
leach is I I was tuning up my my drums
you know I got some back east and it's
his old Slingerland kit and it's a third
at 12 wait
no nine but 13 14 and an 18 it was 1314
Tom's and then an 18-inch floor and a
24-inch kick and I ended up adding
another I found a from the same era a 16
inch floor tom and then I added another
bass drum so I got two 24s all right
this is my first attempt to get to try
to get away from just aping and doing a
bad job of everything John Bonham did I
was getting into Primus and my my
brothers they were playing like speed
metal and [ __ ] and they were trying to
always trying to get me into Metallica
and Slayer and all them and I just I
just was too much of a [ __ ] idiot to
realize how great
music was and I could have seen all
those bands on their first tours and I
didn't do it so anyways I went home and
I was tuning up the bass drum and I just
couldn't get a good [ __ ] sound and it
was this weird like vibrating [ __ ]
sound or whatever and I text my teacher
I said yeah I'm getting this weird like
a buzzer or a tone he said is there a
hole in the front head and I was like
this guy is a [ __ ] genius [ __ ]
genius kids what happened is there
wasn't a hole in the front head but
where they were something fell on it and
punctured just a little list of hole I
said it was a tiny hole he goes that
would be enough to [ __ ] it up because I
couldn't get that boom sound and so now
I'm like obsessing about it I got to get
I get hit back aged again I want to try
tuning him up again and I've now become
obsessed with like different heads and I
used to be so afraid to try and tune my
drums I'd have somebody else do it and
then I just wouldn't touch him and I
play him until they sucked again and
then I hope I could find somebody else
rather than just biting the bullet and
being like just take out your drum key
and start [ __ ] with it and ask people
who know how to do it to teach you how
to do it and keep [ __ ] doing it you
[ __ ] but you know part of being an
[ __ ] is you don't do [ __ ] like that
alright the apocalypse hey there dilly
dilly hey there Billy death bell the
Internet keeps talking about the end of
times as if things today are far worse
than they've ever been I'm only 31 years
old but I seem to remember plenty of bad
weather and shitty presidents there's
this need to make everything sound worse
than it is these days because everyone
loves to be the bearer of bad news and
they get a thrill off the excitement
that [ __ ] may be going south real quick
I saw a quote by John Mayer on Twitter
someone asked him what annoys him and he
says spacious argument it's everywhere I
can't stand it is that it I say that
right
the fetters ate the feta zation of
defense attorney logic gone mainstream
uh uh well he's obviously a smarter
person to me because I don't want any
that means spacious argument it's
everywhere I can't stand it the feta
zation of defense attorney logic gone
mainstream that right there is why he's
a brilliant guitarist cuz I don't know
what the [ __ ] he just did but I don't I
don't know that anybody's ever put words
together like that I don't what that
means I totally agree everyone thinks
they're dropping the mic and they're
just pandering and reaching for
low-hanging fruit now that that I agree
with yes PS keep the nineties music
coming that Fiona Apple song that Andrew
used last week reminded me of the summer
I started jerk enough save the pet store
manager from from last week I don't know
what that means yeah Andrew picks the
music I wish I was could claim that I
was as cool as to know all the [ __ ] that
he does he knows a bunch of our music
yeah there is a lot of that there's a
lot of gloom and doom and all that type
of [ __ ] but uh you know it's not all it
is I I you know the Great Barrier Reef
and all that type of [ __ ] is pretty
terrifying all that [ __ ] is pretty
[ __ ] terrifying and I mean I can't
even focus on it if you actually get
past all the dopes on social media
talking about things and you actually
listened to scientists talking about
like whatever their predictions are I
know that there's I don't know this
sounds like a you know I think it's
gonna be uh you know it should be
interesting we'll see I hope they're
wrong you know who the [ __ ] knows I
don't know alright the DNC everybody
dear mr. burr I am appalled and
disgusted that you had the audacity to
speak poorly of Debbie Schultz Wasserman
a lifelong servant of her country and
the only party that has moved this
country forward I usually enjoy your
brand of humor there's no way this
person's serious I have see I have see
parts of your comedy specials and
overheard a hand
of episodes of your podcasts while in
the proxy of my brother-in-law you sir
have a responsibility to tell the truth
and not just your uninformed opinions on
politics the deceit that you distribute
is going to aid in the dismantling of
this country oh god no God give me a
[ __ ] break he just happened to be
walking by and you heard that well you
know the whole part of this podcast is
that I am uninformed and I sent a link
that you could watch on YouTube and
listen to that lawyer discussing the
things that she did or didn't do so I
don't know what your [ __ ] problem is
you know I talk about politics the way I
talk about sports is someone who never
did it at a professional level I met
Schulz Wasserman a few years back and I
asked her what we could do every day to
change the nation for the better and she
eloquently said do not let them tell you
how to feel oh god I'm not reading the
rest of this this is [ __ ] sincerely a
proud Democrat who will not be
discouraged you know what you sound like
you sound like someone you know when
someone comes up to me and says the
Patriots are cheaters and then I say
who's your team and then I talk about
the [ __ ] that they've done and then they
downplay that yeah you are I got to be
honest with you it's uninformed as I am
people like you I can't even talk to
because you're so lost in your blue ties
that you can't see that it's just you
know what it's like everybody out here
in Hollywood loves to sit there and
trash FoxNews and talk about how they're
all these bullies and all that and I'm
gonna tell you I'm not going to name any
[ __ ] names but the amount of
performers comedians actresses and all
this type of [ __ ] like their level of
zero tolerance like they're they're
literally what they're fighting they're
bullies they tell people how they're
supposed to think the way they're
supposed to think and they feel that
they are 100% right they feel that their
view of the world is the way that the
world should
and anyone who doesn't think that needs
to be attacked needs to be dragged
onstage and humiliated needs to have
their their their ability to earn a
living attacked it's no different than
when you watched what Fox News did to
the Dixie Chicks it's the exact same
[ __ ] thing the exact same level of
righteousness patting themselves on the
back about how [ __ ] smart they are
and how informed they are you know
meanwhile as they fly around and [ __ ]
private jets give me a [ __ ] break
give me a [ __ ] break okay
you know the Patriots cheat your team
cheats the Republicans of pieces of [ __ ]
the Democrats are pieces of [ __ ] all
right
there you go there you go so other than
anything other than that you're looking
at [ __ ] through [ __ ] rose-colored
glasses and I think it's I think that
that is I don't know what to think I
just I can't have a conversation with
that you know I mean it's like if I
listened to a Red Sox fan back what
Derek Jeter was playing and they just
say that he sucks and he's [ __ ]
overrated blah blah and I would just sit
there be like hey he isn't he's [ __ ]
one one of the greatest players of all
time I'd love if he was on my team you
know I hate the Yankees but I'm not
gonna hate on greatness Mariano Rivera
is the greatest [ __ ] closer of all
time I still [ __ ] hate the Yankees
but I don't hate them to a level that I
can't see I can't see that you know what
I mean I just don't I just don't [ __ ]
understand it I don't understand it like
you want to talk about Spygate and the
Patriots were guilty of cheating
deflategate was [ __ ] Spygate was
true however they were only guilty of
doing it for one game and I only clarify
that because everybody thinks well they
should take away all their titles cuz
that's what they were doing know it that
was the first game it was illegal and
they kept [ __ ] doing it alright and
they were 100% guilty and they deserved
to be [ __ ] fine because they were
cheating then yes they were that one
time all the other stuff was [ __ ]
though however if they because I mean
when the flaky egg came out I was like
if they did this [ __ ] again I'm done
with this [ __ ] team that's what I
said and then I watched the whole
[ __ ] thing unfold I was like oh this
was just [ __ ]
so there you go does that sound
even-handed you guys probably think I'm
too much of a Patriots fan but I mean I
did it they Spygate was cheating and
they were guilty they did it one game
Rayman Jeanne [ __ ] ratted them out
then that was that they were [ __ ]
guilty what are you gonna do does that
make them worse than anybody else no
Bill Walsh [ __ ] cheated so there you
go they should Democrats and you're
Republicans say the Patriots are
Democrats I'm a Patriots fan so I am a
Democrat okay but I can see they're
[ __ ] I can see that Spygate was
[ __ ] cheating and they were guilty of
it and I could also see that Bill Walsh
[ __ ] did the same thing when he
pretended his [ __ ] headsets went out
it's not that [ __ ] hard I don't
understand what your point is that the
oh my god this person was just a [ __ ]
amazing person I said what should we do
he said
don't let them capitals tell you how to
feel that is such like that is got to be
the most vague I'm on my way to my town
car [ __ ] horseshit response ever hey
Bill what's your secret to being a
successful stand-up comedian I you know
just get out there and keep doing it man
all right girlfriend won't take racist
last name all right dear Bill's buried
oh boy hey [ __ ] you man I'm under 180
okay go easy go easy you know all right
dear Bill's buried oh boy my girlfriend
of three years has made it very clear
that if we if I were to propose to her
that she would not take my last name the
reason being is that she feels my last
name is racist
the name is Coons spelled co ons I told
her that I have never encountered a
problem having this last name and she
has nothing to worry about thoughts yeah
as my thoughts I think you're making
this up and if you're not that woman is
too dumb to marry and reproduce with
all right if you call a black person a
[ __ ] that is racist if your last name is
Coons it isn't you know look I see if
your last name was the n-word then yeah
I mean maybe you wanna you know yeah I
mean if it's I don't know yet I mean if
that's your [ __ ] last day then that's
a believable last name isn't it you know
what I mean I don't know anyways my
roommate is you know like I'm trying to
think I'm trying to think of a [ __ ]
racial group I can do here without
getting in trouble because I want to
really do a [ __ ] I guess I have to go
against my own my own [ __ ] racist uh
what I do
there's no good ones there's no good
ones with white people because like it
doesn't have an effect on us that [ __ ]
you know I mean I know maybe in the
future some other group takes over and
then we'll have that we'll have our you
know you can't call me cracker
I love crackers I love putting cheese on
my roommate is a [ __ ] weirdo dear
[ __ ] i'ma [ __ ] [ __ ] first of all a big
fan of the [ __ ] podcast the last
[ __ ] Netflix special was phenomenal
so thanks okay that means is one of
these people that thinks because I swear
that now they have to swear you don't
have to bring yourself down to my level
sir anyways I just [ __ ] moved into
college as a freshman my roommate is a
hot [ __ ]
I mean I'm gay so right away I was into
him but I kept to myself since I had no
way of knowing he was gay too
I thought you guys had gaydar you
couldn't sense it so last week on Friday
after a [ __ ] drunken night out we
returned to our room oh geez here we go
and the [ __ ] guy offhandedly tells me
he's gay once the conversation started
getting more personal then I told them
I'm also gay and this guy says [ __ ] I
don't think this is real after which we
proceeded to [ __ ] which was [ __ ]
amazing by the way I find the term I
find the [ __ ] term endearing so [ __ ] all
the political correctness hysteria by
gays and non gays alike
alright I'm just gonna read this okay
anyways this is when the [ __ ] started to
hit the fan no pun intended
sorry dude you lobbed it over the
[ __ ] net once I came he expressed
disappointment at the volume of my [ __ ]
does anyone believe this is true the
[ __ ] literally said that's it
what are you sick or something I felt
[ __ ] inadequate since his load was
considered sickness really bigger than
mine Jesus Christ so then the next
morning he says he wants to [ __ ] again I
go along with it like he's so hot I'm
not gonna refuse halfway through this
[ __ ] says you know for a tall
guy you sure have a small dick and he
writes like what the [ __ ] yeah well dude
you came back for more abuse here so I'm
all for two right inadequate dick size
check lack of Herculean [ __ ] shot check
is insulting the people he [ __ ] part of
his style like I can't figure out why he
still wants to [ __ ] me after two
colossal [ __ ] insults so what the
[ __ ] do I do next we'll stop [ __ ] the
guy [ __ ] knows but the next day we're
chugging tears in our room you know
other than the gay sex it sounds amazing
that's sorry I'm looking this as a
straight guy what the [ __ ] am I uh okay
we're chugging beers in Romi suggests
something beyond weird
oh god he basically tells me he wants me
to pee in his mouth you know even if
this is fake this is tremendously
creative you got to give this up okay
since it turns him since it turns a mom
I'm eight beers deep and I'm a
lightweight so I'm like [ __ ] I do it
I swear to God if this is true and you
piss in this guy's mouth and he's
labeled go on sir that's it
this [ __ ] has a stream like a
goddamn fire hose and nearly broke my
jaw in the process what I don't believe
Jesus Christ so I'm completely weirded
out by this colossal [ __ ] dude you let
him piss in your mouth
his only saving grace is that he happens
to be the hottest guy ever met so bill
what the [ __ ] do I do do I change room
kick this [ __ ] to the curb and sleep and
never sleep with a [ __ ] or do I stick
stick in there so that I can stick it in
there thanks and go [ __ ] yourself you
monkey [ __ ] I don't know it sounds like
you feel bad afterwards if I was with a
woman and she was doing this [ __ ] to me
and she was really hot yeah I'd probably
keep going back but I would just get
myself mentally prepared you know what
you might do just telling me has a weird
[ __ ] you gotta get in his head tell
him his ass is too hairy he needs to
braid the hair on his ass or so I don't
know what the [ __ ] that I mean I know
you're outside you know this is still
basically human interaction so you're
talking about feelings here so if you
want to get childish say something mean
to him and I don't know you know what's
weird is the just just showed up now I
have to smoke a cigar after reading that
[ __ ] yeah dude don't [ __ ] go back
don't go back for more fright or if
you're going to go back for more sorry
I'm texting hang on all right yeah you
don't need to put up with that [ __ ]
everything's like a pawn in this the
weird thing is that you live with the
guy it's never good to [ __ ] your
roommate you know it's that's that's
never gonna be a good thing but I don't
know how it works with gay guys cuz
you're both guys right so I would think
you'd be able to just be like yeah we're
just [ __ ] right then we'll watch a
game and [ __ ] drink some beers and
I'll [ __ ] piss in your mouth
evidently I guess that's how it goes
down I don't know what the [ __ ] happens
here so I would just if he sincerely is
making you feel bad then I would I would
try to find a better guy but consider
you live with them you office Lee thank
you you can just blow the guy off so at
some point he's gonna be like hey man
you want a [ __ ] you gotta be like no I
don't be like why not because you're a
dick
you say mean [ __ ] to me and I don't like
it all right so why don't you go in
there and go rub one out and piss in
your own [ __ ] mouth you [ __ ]
douche or you just move out all right
that's the podcast everybody god bless
each and every one of you go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check it on you on
Thursday